to my fans my family my sponsorship
and the haters i greatly apologize
if i let you guys down and i did and i
just want to let y'all know this will be
the last time to
olympics don't cheat shakira richardson
and this will be the last time the u.s
doesn't come home with a gold medal in
100. u.s
track sensation shakiri richardson is
apologizing
according to the united states
anti-doping agency
the 21 year old track and field sprinter
tested positive for marijuana
following her olympic qualifying 100
meter race victory
at the olympic trials in eugene oregon
on june 19th
as a result the usada announced on
friday that shakiri has accepted a
one-month suspension
a penalty she spoke out about on
friday's today show
i want to take responsibility for my
actions i know what i did i know what
i'm supposed to do
no no i'm allowed not to do and i still
made that decision but um not making an
excuse or looking for any
empathy in my case but just however
being in that position of my life
finding out something like that
something that i would say is probably
one of the biggest things that have
impacted me
positively and negatively in my life
when it comes to
dealing with the relationship i have
with my mother shakiri is referring to
the death of her biological mother
a few days before her olympic qualifying
trial
she says she learned the news that her
mother had died during an interview
from a reporter a moment she calls quote
triggering and
nerve shocking and led her to using
marijuana as a coping mechanism
which is against the rules in sports but
legal in the state of oregon
i want you to tell me that like you know
it's like
no offense against him at all he's just
doing um his job but definitely that set
me in a state of mind in a state of
of emotional panic if anything
and still knowing that i still even
though i'm here i still have to go out
and put on a performance for um put up a
performance for my dream but after you
still compete
so what it is so yes definitely trigger
and
from there just blind and blinded by
emotions blinded by
bad news blinding by just
hurting hiding her still shakiri remains
profusely apologetic
and shares a message she wants everyone
to understand
i apologize as much as i'm disappointed
i know that when i swim on the track i
don't represent myself i represent a
community
that has shown me great support great
love i'm human
we're human when it comes to shakira
richardson
it's never been a steroid it will never
be a steroid attached to the name
chickary richardson the
charge and what the the situation was
was marijuana
i'm not encouraging anybody to do it i'm
not saying oh don't do it
or anything like that but if you choose
to do things um
in your personal time or things like
that you just should know all right be
aware of the consequences don't judge me
because i am human i'm i'm you i just
happen to run a little faster
as for what's next the new york times
notes that
while shakiri can no longer compete
individually in the 100 meter race
she could be cleared in time to run the
100 meter relay
that takes place later in the games if
she's named to team usa
regardless shakiri says she's still
chasing her olympic dreams
full speed ahead this is just one game
i'm 21 i'm very young
unlike most i have plenty of games left
in me to compete in
and i have plenty of talent that backs
me up because like
everything i do comes to me naturally no
steroid
no anything this incident was about
marijuana so
after my sanction is up i'll be back and
able to compete
and no doubt shakiri has the support of
many adoring fans
like gabrielle union who tweeted on
thursday quote
weed is great for many a thing but
running faster
isn't one of them let her run
you